[Musique]
le 8 30 france info sur france info
radio kanal 27 de la tnt on est avec
jean jérôme bertolus chef du service
politique de france info bonjour jean
jérôme bons joueurs si une bourre jours
patrick mignola bonjour notre invité ce
matin patrick mignola donc président du
groupe modem à l'assemblée nationale
alors on va commencer par parler de la
coop 26 qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui à
glasgow en écosse conférence mondiale
sur le climat on est très loin de tous
les objectifs qui ont été fixés
honnêtement ces conférences elles
servent à quoi
à relancer la dynamique depuis 2015 ya
eu des efforts qui ont été faits on peut
pas dire que rien n'a été fait mais on
est comme vous l'avez très bien dit loin
de la balle loin des objectifs
l'objectif on le rappelle c'était 2050
un réchauffement de la planète limitée à
un degré et demi ou à 2 degrés ça
n'arrivera pas manifestement aujourd'hui
on est en difficulté parce qu' il
faudrait un mouvement mondial et on a du
mal en particulier à convaincre les
états unis et la chine c'est exactement
ce à quoi doit servir un sommet de ce
type là pour que les européens qui ont
probablement un peu d' avance à la fois
dans la conviction et dans les
initiatives qui sont prises puis se
convaincre leurs partenaires et puis il
y a eu au delà du volet
atténuation du réchauffement climatique
est aussi un volet qui je crois est très
important pour toutes les populations du
monde et pour les plus jeunes en
particulier il ya le volet adaptation
parce que quoi qu'il arrive même si on
faisait les efforts les plus sûres
humains pour parvenir à atteindre cet
objectif un degré et demi ou deux degrés
de plus en 2050 c'est d'énormes
changements dans nos vies quotidiennes
sur les littoraux sur l'agriculture sur
la viticulture par exemple en france et
d'ores et déjà il faut qu'on lance un
plan stratégique donc voilà qu'on arrête
les incantations et les génuflexions
aujourd'hui je crois que dira la grande
majorité des pays du monde sont
persuadés qu'il faut faire quelque chose
mais que non seulement on agisse
notamment sur l'énergie produire de
l'énergie propre et on est à côté de
l'énergie avoir des plans métier par
métier font que on s'adapte aux
nouvelles énergies propres ça veut dire
que en france
ça passe par la relance de la filière
nucléaire en fait c'est mathématique là
on n'est pas dans une théologie on
regarde même si on fait tous les efforts
nécessaires pour réduire nos
consommations d'énergie parce que la
meilleure énergie c'est évidemment celle
qu'on consomme pas il faut qu'on puisse
développer de l'énergie verte non
carbonées qui n'aimait pas des gaz à
effet de serre nucléaire parce que ce
sont les financières qui font monter le
leu leu à chaleur de la planète ça veut
dire nucléaire ça veut dire
hydroélectricité et c'est très important
parce que en france nous sommes des
leaders en matière d'hydroélectricité et
de nucléaire donc ça permet d'avoir une
indépendance énergétique ne pas être
dépendant par exemple du gaz russe et
évidemment les énergies renouvelables
une toute petite question le président
de la république emmanuel macron doit
s'exprimer avant la fin la coque 26 le
12 novembre sur la politique énergétique
en france probablement puisque on va
avoir devant nous une obligation
qui est de convaincre nos partenaires
européens savaient en matière de climat
au même titre qui a eu un plan marshall
je crois qu'avec la présidence française
de l'union européenne au 1er janvier on
pourrait avoir un plan macro pour le
crime de le climat au niveau européen ça
veut dire discuter nos partenaires
allemands qui ont arrêté le nucléaire
mais sont en grande difficulté parce que
maintenant ils émettent beaucoup plus de
gaz à effet de serre que nous avec leurs
centrales à charbon ils sont en train de
discuter dans la nouvelle coalition dans
laquelle il ya les écologistes pour
savoir s'ils arrêtent en 2035 ou en 2030
leurs centrales à charbon il ya
évidemment les discussions avec l'europe
de l'est avec la pologne on voit bien
qu'il est au niveau les discussions pour
savoir au niveau européen si le
nucléaire est une énergie décarbonée et
verte exactement
et c'est une occasion formidable pour
l'europe de créer demain des produits
décarbonés donc c'est même une ouïe art
unités commerciales de parlement patrick
mignola on va passer à la crise
sanitaire maintenant je devrais
commencer par une question qui peut
sembler annexes mais qu'il n'est pas
forcément celle de ses terrasse éphémère
qui finalement ne le seront pas puisque
dispositif va être reconduit chaque
année elles doivent être théoriquement
remise et demain ça pose énormément de
problèmes beaucoup de municipalités dans
certains arrondissements de paris de
marseille et aux riverains aussi vous en
dites quoi
aujourd'hui que si on regarde ce qui
s'est passé avec la crise coheed
on a quand même envie de se réunir à
nouveau mais si possible à l'air libre
il a remarqué comme c'est difficile
aujourd'hui de fréquenter des cinémas
les gens regardent le cinéma de chez eux
avec netflix mais ils vont de moins en
moins au cinéma parce qu'ils n'aiment
pas les endroits fermés et quand vous
avez un restaurant bas c'est beaucoup
mieux d'avoir une terrasse y compris
l'hiver oui et quand vous êtes un
riverain qui habite au dessus elle reste
un problème en fait vous avez deux
choses à faire pour le les terrasses
extérieures d'abord elles sont souvent
chauffer donc on retrouve le sujet
précédent bon on arrive à chauffer des
terrasses mais de manière décarbonés
cercle faut qu'on soit capable grâce aux
énergies renouvelables grâce au
nucléaire grâce à l'hydroélectricité
plutôt chanceux nuisances et
l'occupation de l'espace public et la
deuxième chose c'est effectivement qu'on
soit capable
d'amoindrir le bruit à la hausse et on a
fait ça dans les établissements
scolaires moi quand j'étais maire
j'avais mis des des objets sur tous les
restaurants scolaires qui permettait
d'amoindrir le bruit d'étape qui font -
druide et chaises qui font moins de
bruit ouais vous avez des gros blocs de
mousse qui avale le bruit si on veut
arriver à vivre ensemble
sérieusement vous pensez que des blocs
de mousse vont permettre de résoudre ce
genre de projet à écouter à la ravoire
où j'étais maire on a fait baisser de 20
décibels la moyenne du bruit émis et ben
si on arrive à mettre des blocs de bruit
des blocs antibruit et concis attention
fait l'énergie décarbonée et bien dans
ce cas là vous vous arrivez à faire
vivre les gens en terrasse sans trop
déranger le voyage c'est dans cette
société faut qu'on arrive à supporter un
peu les uns les autres des terres
intérêts sous conditions et faut-il
avoir également un pass sanitaire est
bien sous conditions ou plutôt
effectivement est ce qu on pourrait se
passer de son utilisation à certaines
conditions aujourd'hui le sénat met en
garde la majorité parlementaire et le
gouvernement écoute et philippe bas
c'est le rapporteur du projet de loi sur
la vigilance sanitaire
quand
dans un département nos concitoyens sont
très largement vacciner plus besoin du
pass sanitaires et quant au contraire
ils ne sont pas assez vacciner alors oui
le pass sanitaire peut éventuellement
être reconduit si le gouvernement ne
décide
est-ce que ça n'est pas tout simplement
du bon sens patrick mignola comme
d'ailleurs la volonté du sénat de
limiter l'application du pass sanitaire
jusqu'au 28 juillet et non pas comme
vous le souhaitez jusqu'au 31 juillet
écoutez je vais vous dire changement de
bertolus moi je crois que le sénat doit
pas faire de politique politicienne et
moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
sénateurs j'ai beaucoup d'ennemis
sénateurs à commencer par arriver
marseille quelques et le président du
groupe union centriste mais franchement
nous rentrons dans une période
électorale est ce qu'on imagine sérieux
de revoter une loi de prévoir maintenant
qu'on va voter une loi en février en
février à un mois ou un mois et demi du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ce sera l'objet de toutes
les polémiques ce sera l'objet de tous
les affrontements on va prendre en otage
la santé des français
alors que
en cette période électorale et avec une
éventuelle reprise épidémique qu'on voit
poindre est ici ou là il faut se laisser
les moyens d'utiliser le pass annie
terre et les mesures de freinage fait
bouger été dans mon intention canaux me
romain sentiront pour le rappel des
titres mais d'un mot pas de compromis
avec le sénat non mais si le compromis
c'est de dire qu' on doit débattre
effectivement c'est précisément le
groupe modem par la voix de philippe
vigier qui a demandé à ce qu'il y ait un
débat au mois de février sur le sujet
solitaire il y aura un débat mais
refaire une loi tous les trois mois
alors que l'objectif c'est de protéger
les français je crois que ce serait pas
une bonne mesure patrick mignola invités
de 8,30 france info voici le fil info
avec diane von trips nouvelle président
du groupe modem à l'assemblée nationale
qui est l'invité du 8 30 france info ce
matin jean jérôme bertolus encore un
accident de chasse cette fois en ille et
vilaine
les verts veulent interdire la chasse à
certaines périodes écoutez l'explication
d'eva sas la porte-parole d' écologie
les verts
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron est un peu
l'otage du lobby des chasseurs alors que
la majorité des français sont plutôt
pour un encadrement de la chasse et nous
c'est ce que nous proposons il faut
avoir un accès égal à la nature et qu'on
puisse se promener tranquillement
effectivement le week end et les
vacances scolaires donc nous demandons
effectivement l'interdiction de la
chasse
sur ces périodes là parce qu'il faut pas
réguler un petit peu la chasse est ce
que ces accidents font pas un peu peur à
tous les français qui sort pas leurs
fusils le week-end ou durant les
vacances
et moi j'ai une expérience personnelle
très difficile sur ce sujet puisque je
vous rappelle tout à l'heure que j'étais
maire j'ai un de mes adjoints qui a été
tuée par un chasseur sur un de ses
terrains où il cueillait des champignons
il ya quelques années et ça a été un
drame pour sa famille pour toute la
commune est bien sûr qu'il faut il faut
mieux réguler
les associations de chasse font bien
leur travail
mais elles peuvent encore faire des
efforts que ce soit sur un meilleur
encadrement
de ceux qui détiennent de cartes de
chasse des permis de chasse que ce soit
sur certaines pratiques qui paraissent
plus vraiment adapté à l'époque par
exemple mais on peut pas vous avez
certaines pratiques de chasse où on voit
bien aujourd'hui que il ya une
souffrance animale on a légiféré sur le
bien-être animal à l'assemblée nationale
et on ne peut pas continuer dans ces
conditions là qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire que les chasseurs excusez moi mais
moi je suis qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire c'est quoi les pratiques qu'il faut
bannir aujourd'hui sur les pièges vous
pouvez avoir des animaux qui est qu'ils
vont être emprisonné est
en souffrance pendant des heures et des
heures pour éviter ces accidents mais je
trouve que la vision des écologistes
enfin deux élevés en l'occurrence parce
que tous les écologistes sont peu élevés
heureusement
c'est une vision hyper radical parce que
si demain vous interdisait la chasse le
week-end vous interdisez la chasse tout
court parce que des chasseurs il n'y a
pas que des retraités et on va pas la
chasse le mardi et le mercredi
uniquement et si vous affrontez de
radicalité d'un côté des chasseurs qui
ne veulent pas bouger alors qu'ils
doivent bouger et doivent l'entendre et
de l'autre les écologistes qui veulent
interdire la chasse on s'en sortira pas
moi j'aimerais je rêve eh bien on doit y
arriver dans une société moderne quand
même que des écologistes et des
chasseurs puis se mettre autour de la
table et regarder comment on fait
évoluer il faut la table ronde sur la
chasse aujourd'hui n'est évidemment vous
nargue les tableaux où les gens se
comprennent et au lieu de rester sur des
positions
bloqués
en appelant de part et d'autre comme l'a
fait face à l'instant à l'arbitrage du
président de la république mais que les
gens se parlent mais vous dire des
chasseurs ils doivent bouger dans quel
sens vous avez deux solutions vous avez
deux situations la première situation il
faut une meilleure surveillance des
permis de chasser le l'accident auquel
je faisais référence tout à l'heure
c'était une personne à laquelle on avait
enlevé son permis de chasse pour des
raisons personnelles sur lesquelles je
ne vais pas revenir mais finalement ses
amis continuer de l'emmener chasser on
peut pas se permettre ça parce que ça
genre seront se mettre dans l'illégalité
d'enfouissement de contrôle voilà
clairement il faut que les plus gros
lots et un autocontrôle et en plus les
sociétés de chasse responsable de la
part des sociétés de chasse et
aujourd'hui elles sont suffisamment
responsables pour le faire et vous avez
de l'autre de la part des écologistes la
nécessité de comprendre que dans la
société on peut pas avoir un modèle
unique
c'est quand les écologistes vous dise ce
que vous avez le droit faire et pas
faire la façon dont vous devez vous
déplacer ou pas la façon dont vous devez
manger ou pas la façon dont vous devez
choisir vos loisirs ou pas je pense que
ça fonctionne pas dans la société il n'y
a pas un modèle unique fois je suis
aussi favorable à un modèle de liberté
mais deux responsables modèlerie une
dernière question une dernière question
sur lui c'est celui où vous mangez plus
de viande ou vous avez l'interdiction
d'habiter dans des maisons individuelles
où vous mangez plus de fromage c'est ce
que disent les écologistes et puis et
puis vous n'avez plus droit de chasse et
non plus
uniquement c'est une question sensible
soyons concrets vous dites est plus de
contrôles de la part des sociétés de
chasse vis-à-vis de leurs adhérents et
vous demandez quoi aussi plus de
formation d'un mot plus une meilleure
formation des chasseurs alors que le
permis de chasse a vu son prix baisser
ces derniers temps oui il faut bien un
meilleur accompagnement il faut vérifier
à période régulière que les personnes
ont une santé physique psychologique qui
leur permet de chasser mais comme on le
fait dans n'importe quel club de sport
d'ailleurs chaque fois on vous demande
un certificat médical et les chasseurs
doivent entendre qu' ils doivent évoluer
de la même façon qu'ils doivent entendre
qu'on n'est pas sur la ligne d écologie
qui veulent tout interdire la transition
est un petit peu difficile mais quand
même quand même il y a quelques semaines
vous avez noté effectivement qu emmanuel
macron était dans un refuge de la spa
société protectrice des animaux et à
cette occasion emmanuel macron indiqué
un chasseur il aime son chien il aime
les animaux sinon il ne ferait pas de
chasse ma question c'est est ce que le
président de la république est d'ores et
déjà candidats mais selon m
alors il n'est pas candidat parce que
sinon on serait certainement au courant
mais il est probablement un candidat
crédible sans s'être déclarés alors que
d'autres candidats déclarés sont moins
crédibles facile je regarde la course
des petits chevaux à droite où la course
à la démagogie effectivement voilà moi
je suis relativement un patient en fait
qu'ils soient candidats pour que
on essaye de revenir dans un débat
public un peu un peu chance est un peu
responsable qui défendre un modèle que
que face à un problème on propose des
solutions plutôt que trouver des
coupables voyez ce ce modèle
ce modèle français d'une grande
démocratie humaniste qui défend la
liberté la justice sociale l'engagement
écologique ba aujourd'hui il est le seul
à le porter et au moment où il rentrera
dans le débat public peut-être qu'on
passera un peu moins de temps dans les
dents les polémiques tels qu'on les voit
ce qu'est ce qu'il faut que ça arrive
vite notamment pour répondre à marine le
pen et à eric zemmour
pas d'un porte pour vous c'est le niveau
d'importance vous avez vous avez une
difficulté qui est la présidence
française de l'union européenne je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure la france va
présider aux destinées de l'europe à
partir du 1er janvier et c'est
certainement ce que le président de la
république a dans l'esprit pour décider
ou non de déclarer sa candidature à
l'élection présidentielle
ça n'empêche pas de commencer à se
préparer et tous ses amis tous ceux qui
ont envie qu'il soit candidat l'ex
sphère actuelle de ce qui se dit des
idées qui sont débattues ne nécessite
pas une entrée plus rapide du président
de la république dans sa campagne selon
vous écouter
l'atmosphère actuelle à laquelle vous
faites référence
où effectivement pour le moment on est
dans la recherche de boucs émissaires
moi j'ai bien compris que on avait
l'extrême gauche qui s'agitait beaucoup
pour expliquer que tout ça était la
faute des riches que l'extrême droite
c'est gîte est beaucoup pour expliquer
que tout ça était la faute des musulmans
il faut laisser se dérouler le concours
de bouc émissaire et puis à un moment
donné revenir à une forme de rationalité
où on parlera des véritables problèmes
des français et y compris du problème de
l'identité c'est une question l'identité
c'est normal après la crise qu'on vient
de vivre et après les dents les
évolutions scientifiques et
technologiques convie tous que les
français puissent se s'interroger sur ce
qu'ils sont et sur ce qu'ils vont
devenir
mais il faut apporter des réponses à ça
il faut pas désigner des coupables
patrick mignola invités de 8,30 france
info l'heure du fil d'infos pour
l'instant 20h50 avec diane président du
groupe modem à l'assemblée patrick
mignola est l'invité de 8,30 france info
ce matin jean jérôme bertolus encore une
question politique patrick mignola
est ce que la majorité présidentielle va
s'organiser est ce que cette fameuse
maison commune ce parti commun qui
pourrait réunir dans un premier temps le
modem et la république en marche va être
portée sur les fonts baptismaux on dit
le dernier week-end de novembre oui
monsieur c'est déjà le cas très
largement à l'assemblée nationale c'est
vrai qu'on travaille très bien on peut
innover la wind et vous contourner et il
faut aussi
essayer d'expliquer que ça existe déjà
et là où ça existe ça marche et donc là
où ça n'existe pas c'est à dire dans les
parties effectivement il faut qu'on le
fasse faut qu'on fasse ce rapprochement
d'ici la fin du mois de novembre qu'on
soit prêt alors c'est ça la nouveauté
vous avez richard ferrand françois
bayrou s'en occupe sur les sujets de
partis politiques en général faut pas
être plus de deux ou trois sinon ça fait
vite cinq ou six avis différent donc moi
je je je fais toute confiance à ces deux
personnalités éminentes pour que se
construisent au fond ce grand mouvement
central de la vie politique française
tout simplement parce qu'il faut qu'on
soit prêt à aller sur le terrain la
campagne a pas se faire que sur les
réseaux sociaux et en visio et donc on a
des groupes parlementaires qui
fonctionne il faut un parti qui
fonctionne il ya des associations qui
secret d'élus locaux soutenant le
président de la république pour sa
réélection c'est très bien géré il faut
qu'on retourne sur le terrain puis ce
sera très rapidement de se retrouver un
peu plus en tout cas de nous il faut
qu'on soit prêt qu'on fasse les choses
sérieusement pour que le moment venu
quand le président de la république
décidera des deux candidats ont soit
prêt à aller au contact toute autre
question mais une question très sensible
après le suicide de dina cette
adolescente de 14 ans qui avait été
harcelé dans son lycée le député modem
du haut-rhin bruno fuchs indique qu'il
veut déposer une proposition de loi sur
le harcèlement scolaire est ce que vous
en tant que patron du groupe modem à
l'assemblée vous allez soutenir cette
initiative
la nouvelle encadrement en quelque sorte
enfin ou d'une nouvelle manière de
réprimer le harcèlement scolaire non
seulement je la soutiens mais le
gouvernement le soutient également
puisque jean castex avec qui j'en ai
parlé la semaine dernière
m'a donné son accord pour que le
gouvernement soutienne cette proposition
si nous la déposerons donc on aura une
semaine de l'assemblée nationale au mois
de décembre donc la loi est déposé ce
serait une loi balanant puisque erwan
balanant qu'est député modem également
chef avait avait fait un rapport sur ce
sujet très fouillée très précis a déposé
une proposition de loi est aujourd'hui
on va travailler avec bien sûr le
ministre de la justice avec le ministre
de l'éducation nationale on va
rencontrer très rapidement les syndicats
d'enseignants parce qu'il faut
travailler à leurs côtés parce
qu'évidemment il s'agit pas de mettre en
cause la communauté éducative au sens
large du terme personnel enseignant
personnalise dernière voire apporte un
délai cette loi une qualification pénale
autonome et il faut qu'on discute de ça
justement parce que ça peut
éventuellement effrayer les acteurs
quand vous créez une qualification
pénale aux hommes qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que vous avez un délit
de harcèlement qui existe dans notre
droit vous avez une qualification pénale
sur le harcèlement moral une
qualification pénale sur le harcèlement
sexuel et on peut en faire une sur le
harcèlement scolaire pourquoi vous avez
deux objectifs le premier objectif c'est
d'envoyer d'abord un message à
l'ensemble de la société la communauté
éducative je le disais ça les
enseignants lennon enseignants ce sont
les parents d'élèves ce sont les
personnels de direction c'est chacune et
chacun dans la société qui doit lutter
contre ces drames mais ça changera quoi
ah pardon pour les harceleurs de savoir
qui est un délit particulier d'abord
qualification
souvent il n'ya pas il n'y a pas qu'un
seul responsable mais ça peut arriver
donc quand il ya qu un seul responsable
ils pourraient être condamnés on sait
bien que ça peut arriver dans certains
établissements d'avoir
le grand qui essayent de dents et millet
d'embêter de harceler et puis on sait
comment tout ça peut finir en tragédie
mais au delà c'est un travail de
prévention comme vous le savez dans les
entreprises quand il alors que je les
lis sur le harcèlement sexuel le
harcèlement moral dans toutes les
entreprises en a mis en place des
procédures des procédures d'alerté des
référents qui sont en charge de détecter
les difficultés et d'accompagner la
question en fait c'est pas de trouver le
coupable en aval pour le condamner
c'est de faire de la prévention en amont
donc cent des personnes et des
personnels en plus présentes dans
l'établissement des personnels qui sont
formés à la détection plémentaires
peut-être les enseignants a peut-être
des administratifs exactement parce que
quand vous avez ça intéressait moi je je
pense que dans le monde scolaire on
manque d'infirmières et en manque de
psychologues et pas seulement d'ailleurs
sur le sujet du harcèlement scolaire
dans notre société on a besoin d'un
meilleur accompagnement des enfants et
il ya évidemment le rôle prééminent des
parents mais on élève bien un enfant
qu'à travers une communauté à travers un
parent collectif mais là non oui à
l'école il ya les associations y aller
par an et il ya toutes celles et ceux
qui peuvent porter une attention et une
sensibilité particulière des enfants et
ça vaut pour lutter contre le
harcèlement scolaire et ça vaut aussi
pour la réussite scolaire une dernière
question donc cette proposition de loi
soutenu par le gouvernement
sera débattu à l'assemblée en décembre
est-ce que vous avez bon espoir de la
faire voter avant la fin de la mandature
c'est ça l'objectif de toute façon
aujourd'hui
il faut pas mentir aux français on
arrive bientôt à la fin de la
législature donc toute initiative
nouvelle comprend il faut qu'on soit sûr
de pouvoir la faire aboutir et donc ce
sera une discussion ensuite avec le
sénat je compte sur marc fesneau mon
collègue ministre des relations avec le
parlement mon collègue du modem pour
qu'il puisse l'inscrire ensuite au sénat
moi je ne doute pas parce que les
sénateurs ils sont très sensibles aussi
que nous pourrions votée avant la fin de
la dictature c'est à dire avant la fin
du mois de février une loi sur le
harcèlement scolaire et ce serait je
crois avec le revenu d'engagement jeunes
avec le le contrat une jeune un jaune
une solution ce serait une bonne façon
de terminer cette législature en la
mettant sous le signe de la jeunesse et
de la réussite une toute dernière
question qui n'a rien à voir après les
jo qui vont se tenir à paris en 2024
jiho d'été donc vous êtes
de sa voix je le rappelle est ce que
vous seriez pour s'il ya une petite
musique qui commence à monter que la
france présente sa candidature pour les
jo d'hiver en 2032 bah oui et puis vous
le dit très bien moi je trouvais ça
formidable parce qu'on a vécu
l'expérience de d'albertville 1992
avoir les jeux olympiques de nouveau
dans les alpes ce sera bien et ce serait
une candidature de la france parce que
même si je suis savoyard ça peut pas
être une candidature personnelle je suis
d'accord avec laurent wauquiez une fois
n'est pas coutume qui disait que ça
pouvait une candidature des alpes savoie
haute-savoie isère au fond et peut-être
même modèle que les alpes françaises
puissent recevoir les jo ce serait une
formidable perspective merci patrick
mignola président du groupe modem à
l'assemblée nationale invité de 8,30
france info ce matin